the capital city of oslo norway is in
the middle of a cultural renaissance
including its dynamic food scene and
it's where chef espen hong bao bang who
actually hails from denmark introduced
reimagined nordic cuisine to the world
through his restaurant mimo the only
three-star michelin restaurant in the
country where reservations must be made
months in advance for a dining
experience that lasts up to four hours
and i was lucky enough to give it a try
off the pristine waters of the oslo
fjord
in the land of the midnight sun
a new age of culture is blossoming in
the heart of the norwegian capital
and behind the subtle yet grand entrance
is the start of an exceptional dining
experience
a doorbell is required to get into mimo
one of the country's most esteemed
restaurants the unexpected pairings
revealed inside constructed with
exacting detail by chef espen hobau bang
the restaurant tour takes diners on a
culinary tour of norway with a creative
menu of contemporary and hyper seasonal
dishes it's about finding new stuff but
also about finding the right quality
making sure that whatever comes in is
just the way we want it would you call
your cuisine traditional norwegian
cuisine i don't want to call it anything
really but we're definitely inspired by
traditional cuisine
known for enduring long winters
norwegians relied heavily on pickling
and preserving methods they still
incorporate today even as oslo has
become a gastronomic hub and pioneering
new nordic cuisine
it seems like there is a sort of
renaissance on what's happening in oslo
right now absolutely yeah and also like
the general quality is just getting
better because people kind of feed off
each other
which also the more good restaurants
there are in the city the better
ingredients we can get our meal at mimo
begins with penichette salted lamb ribs
folded into a crisp rye with forged
spring herbs you're going to get one
bite if you can one bite
all right
it's very flavorful
so we get our diners in a chokehold
right away
is that what you want complete control
the 36 visitors a night don't seem to
mind handing over the rains as they
relish a set yet constantly changing
menu of about 15 dishes the dining
experience in this dark and dramatic
setting has been likened to a
well-choreographed performance a
spectacle for this apparently easily
impressed american oh this is a
presentation
what are they doing what are they doing
here well they're just putting on a
sauce
to get so excited about it i am i'm
excited i'm impressed i don't think i
have people just spooning out sauce in a
little saucepan right in front of me
very often
the sauce salty yet smooth composed of
mussels and dill complement the emulsion
of shucked oysters in their juices it's
like a soothing experience a soothing
experience okay
it's like you have the essence of mother
earth on your tongue fitting for mimo
which means mother earth and finish
hongbao bang incorporates both the
plentiful bounty of the norwegian
coastline one of the world's longest and
the country's forested wilderness it's
important that you know the kitchen
staff also get involved to create that
sort of connection that we can kind of
translate into our cooking and in the
kitchen that they respect
most of all the ingredients
and that respect on even the most micro
level achieves maximum effect
last year mimo was named one of the
world's 50 best restaurants
while home balban prizes the food his
philosophy behind it is much more
relaxed
sometimes i hear chefs talking about
their menus as almost stories that they
tell i know some people say you know
it's a very kind of romantic
you know
description like walking along the water
and came up with an idea this is my
grandma whatever yes honestly i just
want to cook really good food so i just
get inspired by the ingredients and then
just working with it and then things
come up
langoustine langestein also known as
norwegian lobster it's much smaller and
more delicate than its main cousin
mimos is grilled over an open fire
complemented by a sauce composed of the
branches of a black currant bush in its
leaves
i'm actually allergic you're allergic
you are not allergic i am allergic to
this yeah i'll eat it sometimes i'll get
a tickle in my throat but it's going to
be fine like i feel like if i want to go
out yeah
i uh this is the perfect time like i'll
die on television it's worth it to have
this dish it's it's worth dying for it
all right so sweet suck it in oh that's
so delicious it is isn't it
there's also norwegian comfort food
rumigrat a porridge for special
occasions made of milk sour cream flour
and butter
hon bao bang tops it with smoky shaved
reindeer heart with questionably
familiar hints it almost tastes like
bacon yeah but that's just
the delicacy one of my most signature
plates eating the heart is like the
essence blood and heart that's like
the most precious things
like that's what gives the animal life
so obviously for me it's special to eat
that
it's not just hongbao bang's reverence
for food that has made mimo an instant
success
the chef designed nearly everything
inside from the handcrafted furniture to
even the way the food is consumed look
at this one
you did you didn't design this did you
you designed the spoon yes
you designed the plate can you hide the
spoon
you kind of want to snap it
have you tried
you can do it but please don't
that attention to detail has been
critical for the danish chef who was 28
when he opened mimo in 2010. six years
later it was awarded three michelin
stars making him one of the youngest
chefs in the world to achieve that
status
when did you realize it would be a
success
i don't know if i realized that yet i
don't know if we are a success even now
i don't know like three michelin stars
yeah you know you have to
distance yourself a little bit from
like accolades like that the most
important thing is is to immerse
yourself into making your guest happy
that's not a given we need to work hard
at it every day every day every night
that tireless effort ensuring constant
innovation of all this abundant land has
to offer we just want to cook generous
good food
we get inspired by the food culture and
most of all we get inspired by the
ingredients
i think i may have killed him a little
bit when i compared his signature dish
to the bacon the bacon
trying to find spoon the saucepan you
were just
winning over i had a great time i don't
know if he did but
you did a great you did it great you did
you had a couple nice michelle lines and
yeah
well you know what cheers to that then
we we didn't bring anything back from
mimo itself but this is the
national drink in in scandinavia it is
aquavit it is a distilled spirit uh and
flavored with herbs and spices primarily
caraway or perhaps still no deer heart
exceptionally strong
nice job nancy